where do you live mr. kit at the palace  my father's teaching me is trade your  apprentice  of a sort that's very fine to be do they  treat you well better than I deserve  most likely and you they treat me as  well as they're able what's gonna happen  cerio's just throw some stuff at you  some roosters mainly homeless guys  whatever he's got he's really excited  about this but wait don't I get body  armor No  who is there the interrupting cow the  interim we don't wag if you did not let  me finish my response I was to say the  interim oh did you get it again good but  it'll be my way and my cool I assumed  you might say that which is why I have  taken the liberty of gathering your team